[SCREAMING]
I Know this guy he used to be a cop
You and your STAR Labs nerds better put me back together. you were dirty then and you're dirty now
There's a long list of people I want to toss them off rooftops
When you're seeing this stuff like I'm the beauty
Hey everybody we got a whole bunch of flash to break down
There's a little bit more from next week's episode episode 4, but we got our first look at Katee
Sackhoff if you remember I did a video about her right before the season started they announced that she was going to be playing the
blacksmith character Amunet black from the comics
And I talked about her a little bit during my episode 1 video
Because there was a scene with her at the end with killer frost who said I'm not going back talking to that dirtbag who was
Also in the bar with her so I'll explain that in a second
There's a new round of the flash ring giveaway all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
And leave a comment on this video. This is that scene with Caitlin where she talks about Amunet black.
Where have you been... doesn't matter.. Really?
Tell Amunet  that I'm out .You want to quit snow
Doesn't look that way you do what Amunet  says for as long as she tells you
Leave me alone
Freeze touch my hand again, and I'll freeze yourself, maybe some other parts to tell him yeah, I'm done
Don't let your beer get warm
So there's like a really big preview from that episode that I'll break down in a second
But just a circle back around to elongated man stuff because he's gonna be in the next couple of episodes
You see barry punch him in the face, and it just sinks right into his mouth
So it'll explain a little bit about how his powers worked like he just has complete
Elasticity it's a little bit like mr.
Fantastic, but they explained that his character like the way that Barry talks about him in the trailer seems like kind of a dirtbag
But I think he'll wind up being one of the good characters by the end of the season just like last year
HR started out seeming like a dirtbag
But by the end of the season had sort of won everyone over and everybody was really upset that he died
So hopefully they won't kill elongated man after he redeems himself before the finale
But that's all next week that'll sort of tee up his abilities
We'll find out what his relation to the thinker is because the way they're playing it in the trailer
He was also one of the people on that bus but there might be some big twists to it
So just be prepared for that
There are a lot of you that have been asking about the ralph
Dib knee named drop during flash season one they believe that he died during the particle accelerator explosion I
Know I heard a lot of people that night people
You don't even know their names
Jake Davenport
Darya Kim ,Ralph Dimney,  Rothstein, Grant Emerson. Will Everett. Diego Kosta
Ronnie Raymond so either it's a retcon or they'll have a different way of explaining it
But just remember that there were some
Metahumans from back in season one that got powers when the particle accelerator exploded that we didn't learn about till much much later
So it'll be fun to see what they do with the character
But the really cool stuff is
Episode 5 so the week after that they're doing the mini arrow crossover before the big four night crossover
And it's just called girls night out
They're doing Barry's bachelor party in irises bachelorette party so obviously they're building up towards that big wedding
But they're introducing Amunet black Katee Sackhoff's Character and either we're gonna get flashbacks
- what happened to killer frost after the finale when she was working for
Amunet black or she's going to turn into killer frost during the episode because in these promo pictures
She's wearing a new killer frost outfit
That looks like the outfit that she's wearing during the four-night crossover so it's like this blue jacket. It looks fantastic
I loved her costume
But it sounds like after the finale she wound up continuing to be killer frost because she didn't take the serum
So a while ago
I did that comic book video about the thinker arc that Geoff Johns wrote from the Wally West era the
Blacksmith was a big character during that she ran this big metahuman black market
operation called the network
So it sounds like that's also what she's doing on the TV show she's just like a big boss like Richard dragon on arrow is
One of the big bosses of the season it sounds like that's the same thing with Katee, Sackhoff on the flash so the episode
description reads having received an ominous threat from her old boss Amunet Black
Caitlyn fears that her pastime as killer frost may be back to haunt her the producers also explained. She runs an underground
Metahuman Fight Club that I guess the girls go to watch and Barry
Winds up fighting in so that's sort of how they cross over the storylines because at some point you do have to have the flash
versus black Smith in the episode
So I don't know how many more episodes this season
Katee Sackhoff is coming back for but it's probably this one during the first half of the season she might come back
The back half of the season if she gets locked up in iron Heights prison
Like they have that big prison break because remember you have the 12 metahumans that the thinker is trying to collect but in the comics
Blacksmith never really worked with the thinker so they were just sort of two different big bosses
Blacksmith was sort of the leader of the Rogues in Central City while the thinker had taken over a Keystone City
So they were like two separate entities we'll see if they cross them over in the back half though
But the next big thing that they just released was the description for episode six, which is right after the blacksmith episode
And it's going to be sort of a Rick and Morty's style
Council of Rick's episode where they get a bunch of different versions of Harrison wells from the multiverse to form a think tank so obviously
I'll do a new video for that when they release a new preview
But it'll be another week or two before we see any footage from that if you haven't watched Rick and Morty I would recommend that
You check it out most of it's on Hulu
They haven't put season three on there yet, but the council of ricks episode is season 3 episode 7 lawyer is a morty
It's not fair you have no rights, and he's not a lawyer. We just keep him here because he's fun look at him go
Yes slow Rick tall Morty did I graduate eight this time yet? Anything's possible tall Morty?
I'll add a link to that stuff at the end of the video
But a lot of you have also requested that I do a video for the Shazam
Announcement so in the DCEU they just cast the actor. That's going to play Billy Batson
It's going to be Zachary Levi
So just imagine the rock puts him on his workout plan and they just go at each other in their movie
But they're also separately developing a Black Adam spin-off movie
So there are a few questions about how they're using these characters in the DC
EU and who else like Superman or the other characters are going to cross over into them
So I'll do a video for that next that should also post in a couple hours
Announce the next giveaway winner when I post that video
You can click here for that Rick and Morty episode that I was talking about and you can click here for the last big
Justice League trailer, thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight